In this lesson we'll be exploring consistent updates in SDN's.
As a reminder from last lesson, we looked at how to update switch flow table
entries using open flow control commands from the control. The
open flow API however does not provide specific guarantees
about the Level of consistency that
packets along an end-to-end path can experience. So
for example, updates to multiple switches along a
path in a network that occur at different
times may result in problems such as forwarding
loops. Additionally, if updates to the switches along
an end-to-end path occur in the middle of
a flow, Packets from the same flow may
be subjected to different network states. These two problems
are known as consistency problems. The first problem
is known as a packet level consistency problem and
the second problem is known as a flow level
consistency problem. In this lesson, we will explore these
problems in more detail and look at various
approaches to guaranteeing consistent updates in SDNs. To think
about consistency properly, we first need a notion of
a high level programming model that sits on top
of what we would call the southbound interface.
We'll talk about how to write applications, that
use the controller interface that we learned about
in the last lesson. That can rely on
a better notion of consistency, than existing controller
platforms currently provide. Let's first think about how
we want to program these applications. And what
type of abstraction the applications would require from the
underlying control interface.